So we mentioned that you could use
Lucas and Kanade between frames and,
and use the, the, the Shi-Tomasi way of,
of finding features small displacements.
But what if there
are large displacements,
what if things have moved a lot
because they're moving quickly?
Well.
One thing we do is we do know
that we can build a descriptor.
Remember the sift descriptor.
So that if you found a matching point
I'd be able to say yeah I'm
pretty sure that's a match.
But the question was how would
I decide where to find it?
So when we were doing the ransack
method of finding those panoramas
you remember we essentially com,
compared all of these with all of those.
Found the putative matches,
selected a bunch, and
then tried to find something
that gave us a consistent model.
So you're doing a lot of work
in order to try to globally find
all of these kinds of things.
For tracking, what we want is, well,
first of all we typically
want real time methods.
Because we want this thing to
operate as things are moving along.
And in particular, we,
we want this notion of
a coherent tract result, right?
So we're not going to try to
match everything in one frame
to everything in another.
And then do it again,
and then do it again.
And do it again, and do it.
See?
So, you just saw my head
rotating around.
I hope you're paying attention.
So they idea is that you have
this smooth, coherent trajectory.
And that's what we want to do for
tracking.
And in order to do that.
We have to worry about the dynamics.
That is, how are things moving,
how are they changing?
So, when we do tracking
with dynamics the key idea
is we've got some sort
of model of the motion.
Maybe we're updating that model, like
the velocity and acceleration, but using
that model we want to predict where the
objects will be in the next frame and
then we're going to look
around that area, okay?
And that prediction will allow us to
restrict where we're doing the search,
and the other thing is if we have a
noisy detection, that is our ability to
knowing where this thing is not perfect,
we should get a better overall estimate,
because we're combining a prediction
with the measurement, so
that's the idea of
tracking with dynamics.